stallion is on day four of her ex Tory
Lanez shooting trial the rapper was
silent today walking into La Superior
Court he's accused of allegedly firing a
gun at Meg's feet from a car parked
outside this home leaving Kylie Jenner's
party back in 2020 the defense seemed
poised to point the finger at the other
passenger in the car Meg's ex-bff Kelsey
Harris
today Kelsey was back on the stand for
cross-examination after pleading the
fifth and recanting her original
testimony including that she saw Tory
point the gun at Meg Kelsey also
allegedly sent this text to security
obtained by CBS News help Tori shot Meg
if convicted Tori faces more than 22
years behind bars well Todd and Julie
Chrisley just got their date to report
to prison you don't lie you don't cheat
you don't steal last month the reality
TV couple was sentenced to a combined 19
years for fraud and tax evasion the U.S
Marshall service says they must report
to two different federal prisons in
Florida by January 17th